la camioneta de una emisora de radio
envuelta en gas lacrimógeno y otros
periodistas aplicando primeros auxilios
a sus compañeros mientras las protestas
siguen creciendo la policía haitiana ha
sido acusada de una violenta represión
que incluso ha tenido como objetivo a
miembros de la prensa claramente
identificados
las tensiones aumentan en haití con la
población exigiendo la dimisión del
presidente yo ven el móvil
el mandatario joven el moi se está
llegando a su fin no volveremos a la
dictadura
los opositores argumentan que su mandato
presidencial terminó el domingo sitios
desde antes del 7 de febrero la
situación es grave y después de esta
fecha el presidente perdió toda la
legitimidad porque su mandato ha
terminado la situación se ha agravado y
la dictadura empeora
el presidente moix argumenta sin embargo
que juró su mandato de cinco años en
2017 por lo que todavía tiene el poder
hasta febrero de 2022
eeuu ha respaldado esta postura aunque
su embajada emitió un comunicado en el
que dice estar profundamente preocupada
por cualquier acción que pueda dañar las
instituciones democráticas de haití el
domingo funcionarios leales al
presidente afirmaron haber frustrado un
intento de golpe de estado contra él y
arrestaron a 23 personas entre ellas un
juez del tribunal supremo quien obtuvo
este jueves su orden de liberación el
martes moise trató de sacar del cargo a
otros tres jueces que fueron propuestos
como posibles líderes nacionales
interinos por la oposición